quelle france allons nous transmettre à
nos enfants
cette question nous nous la posons à la
fois pour notre niveau de vie les
françaises voient notre pays reculé
année après année et les classes
moyennes en payer le prix
et nous nous la posons aussi pour notre
mode de vie ou pour le dire simplement
les français refusent de devenir
étrangers dans leur propre pays at on
l'impression qu'au bout d'un an les
choses se sont améliorées dans notre
pays
je le dis très clairement la situation
s'est dégradée dans notre pays
moi je suis en retraité je sais ce que
je donne à mâcon tous les mois et il y
en a ras-le-bol est une profession
libérale au niveau des impôts the recent
nettement le coup avec la limitation de
la vitesse à 80 ça impacte fortement les
zones rurales il ya eu la hausse du prix
de l'essence qui a pris 20 centimes
pendant l'été c'est une situation qui
est absolument intenable
donc il ya un mépris des territoires
ruraux mais qui a étouffé la croissance
mais c'était manuel macron
qu'irresponsable de l'avoir asphyxié en
ayant autant augmenter les impôts sur
les français il a créé en un an huit
taxes nouvelles supplémentaires
macron il n'est pas du tout dans la
vraie vie tous les français sont
convaincus aujourd'hui que nous avons
été bernés les classes moyennes les
jeunes les gens qui travaillent tous les
jours on sent vraiment plus en
difficulté avoir de la fierté pour notre
passé avoir de l'affection pour le
présent et avoir de l'ambition pour
l'avenir notre responsabilité est
immense
vive la république et vive la france
[Applaudissements]